- piranhas are those piranhas killer
karaoke feel like that's not a euphemism
they just threw in piranhas she's a this
is gonna go badly for you okay
it's frogs it's just frogs I'm like
imagine my feet snakes alligator she's
likely doing the splits to stay out of
it so she's showing off her vagina
basically did whatever you do don't get
an erection she'll be able to feel it oh
so it's just her sharing a suit with the
do wait and now he just squirted her
with like hot sauce or something I don't
know the waiver system in Thailand but
it's probably what the hell is that that
looks like what the what is that what is
that that's a straight-up dinosaur turd
that he just stuffed her face in it she
doesn't look happy classroom genius it's
kind of like they're using these game
shows it's like a substitute for daycare
like science for kids like it's like
teaching kids how to do scientific
bicycles into a mosquito like how do you
transform a banana tree into a Michael
hey whoever thought of these like
transformations was absolutely hi this
is like some mental level challenges
they're putting these kids through and
they're nailing it why did the buckets
have holes in the bottom these kids are
pretty smart I mean I don't think I'd be
able to do this and how's a kid I feel
like this is like a training program
where Thailand selects its top spies for
the future
now there are pretty much crushing kids
like kids shouldn't be on game shows
they should be like drawing crayons now
they're making the fat kid pull
everybody in a boat to further
accelerate his future back problems
tears tears of like cess
I get this weird sense that they're
gonna be punished if they don't do well
in this competition
this chick is crying oh my god just I
say that this chick is crying I don't
think you got American kids to do this
sunshine day well this looks happier oh
how did I come up with these ideas like
what I officially love this this kind of
reminds me of like you know the
Nickelodeon like game show fix to a
level of bravery of the Thai people that
they're able to do this I would probably
say the eyes are a pink - is that like a
Thailand thing like guys wear pink eye
looks just like her she's singing just
fine why are you dunking her into the
water